The Joe Rogan Experience you know Jackie
Gleason supposedly had an encounter with
Nixon that Nixon and Gleason were
buddies and they were drinking and yeah
yeah that's a famous story that's
disputed but apparently let's go with it
though yeah let's go with it Gleason
apparently it said
um that Jackie Gleason and him were
drinking and uh and Nixon was like
everyone saying [__] UFO
no way yeah and and he flew him to see
wreckage and they had uh Frozen of
biological entities and they got a
chance to see these things that they had
uh that they had Frozen what yeah
what so that must have been like early
70s yeah something like that and Jackie
Gleason wound up having a house built in
the shape of a UFO afterwards no yeah
that was for sale as recently as I think
like a decade ago see if you can find
that house in L.A or something no it's
in Upstate New York
but the house looks like a [__] UFO
no he had a UFO House built
yeah Jackie Gleason apparently was
obsessed with UFOs after the fact yeah
yeah
Upstate New York spaceship house no yeah
and that picture makes it look bigger
okay that's that's serious
that's beautiful oh that's two different
buildings oh yeah oh they have here's
more like the guest house yeah oh I see
small building yeah look at that that's
the other one wild that's amazing yeah
so Jackie Gleason became a UFO freak man
I'm gonna do that after this that's a
pretty cool looking house yeah it's
pretty dope oh my God I wonder if it's
still for sale entrance to the
Mothership let me talk to my wife about
this when I get there yeah this is
serious right here well now you have
this sig spear so they so there's a lot
of UFO stuff on this six spear so maybe
this should be reserved for taking out
the aliens I don't want to take them out
well if they attack you I don't think
they're gonna attack if they attack if
they do attack I think they could render
you useless almost instantaneously but
then too they're kind of like why
wouldn't they just sit back and watch I
think they're if I pass right by if I
had a guess if I had a guess I mean just
the wildest of speculations I would
guess that every civilization reaches a
point of technological proficiency when
they're also dealing with these
territorial
warring tribes where they have the
ability to literally destroy the Earth
and that if this is a natural course of
progression for intelligent beings they
get to this point there's a transition
where it gets very dangerous and if I
was from another planet and I was
monitoring this I would be there to make
sure that they don't launch okay they
don't and that's see that's the theme of
the mothership comedy club is that the
rooms are called fat man and little boy
and the reason why the rooms are called
fat man and little boy is because that
is a specific moment in UFO folklore
when the aliens start arriving after the
detonation of those bombs that's when
you start seeing this massive uptick in
sightings really yes and interactions
with fighter pilots and and and and
these different
military bases that have nuclear
programs where the bases get shut down
and all the power goes off yeah there's
like that's wild yeah it's it's heavy
stuff because if you think that there
are they are watching that would make
the most sense that they see that we
have nuclear power we have the the
ability to blow ourselves up and we
detonate two bombs and then they're like
okay let's [__] let's let's go
monitor these [__] let's go make
sure that to anything that's gonna
affect us in the universe one country
right now has them let's [__]
specifically concentrate on them and
then they have sightings in the Soviet
Union when the Soviet Union has the
capabilities and no yeah there's a
there's a ton of documented sightings
and these encounters that happen and
then beforehand there's not really
anything very little very little very
well I'm sure they've probably been
visiting us if if they do visit us yeah
I would imagine they've been visiting us
forever like look they've got engines
look they've got guns look they've got
this you know it'd be fascinating to
watch like look at these territorial
Apes with nuclear weapons like that's
the time to watch right now they're
probably just sitting back having that
popcorn and feeling like oh man well
it's getting interesting now we're
getting closer and closer to our our
[__] inevitable demise like that's
when the sightings are ramped up to the
point where the Pentagon has to start
talking about and they are yes in front
of Congress yes I mean that's wild yeah
but no one pays attention let's go back
to you know Tick Tock and Instagram well
I mean they kind of pay attention but
it's not there's nothing that you could
[__] put your fork into right you
know it's like what is it you know like
and are why are they telling us about
this that's also there's a lot of
cynicism when it comes to like why is
the government telling us about UFOs
like a distraction you mean but what is
it like what are they telling us because
they really have this information and
they they want to slowly leak it out
because this is an inevitable contact
moment and they want to prepare
civilization or is it just horseshit is
it just they're distracting us and this
is how they you know Institute this
drone program where they have this you
know anti-gravity device and they can
move in the same rates of speed I don't
know I mean it's just guess work that's
crazy yeah that's crazy you could hear
from directly from these guys who've
actually seen it experienced it yeah and
talked with them for a little bit I've
talked to quite a few now quite a few
that have that have seen these things
and have these experiences but the babos
are one is uniquely compelling all right
uniquely compelling because Bob is
without a doubt a brilliant guy and and
he was a legitimate propulsions expert
who it's been proven he worked at Los
Alamos labs and they tried to hide that
they tried to lie about that say that he
wasn't what he was on the employee
roster he uh has a an intimate knowledge
of the facilities they took him George
Knapp took him on a tour of Los Alamos
he knew where everything was he knew the
people there they knew him wow yeah it's
wild [__] man because if he's telling
the truth he says is not one that
they've recovered but multiple and that
one of them they think is really old and
they got it from an archaeological dig
they think that they've recovered this
thing in the ground that's movie stuff I
mean you see that movies and you know we
all watch it in movies and think it's
science fiction but there's a lot of
Science Fiction that has has uh come to
fruition submarines to go under the moon
to there's also space travel in general
flight just flying sure all of it
everything we're just like Buck Rogers
no big deal